hello and welcome to another video my
name is Dave Monterey and I'm here today
with Luke Island Perello in Madrid
capital of Spain now Luke and I have
been speaking a lot about language
learning and one of the topics that have
come up is the subject of developing a
language core now at the first-ever
polyglot conference in Budapest and
maluca gave a presentation about
developing a language core and why it is
important and I thought that it would be
great to share with all of you some of
the great information that will share at
the conference and some of the things
that we have been speaking about during
Lucas time here in Madrid with me and so
Luca how you doing today great ok so the
first question I have for you is really
simple rebase ik it is what is a
language core what is this
to make a long story short language for
means to acquire the ability to send
abusive language the automatic kind of
automatic capacity of speaking one word
beats to the other right so basically
building the language for means to reach
a level of automatism where we can
assemble words and structures together
in an easy in a comfortable way and from
that point we can expand our knowledge
okay fantastic so a language core is
making sure that you have the structure
and you know the vocabulary or the
essential vocabulary of a language
mastered say mastered or learned so that
you can approach the language with ease
is that correct that's correct when some
people believe that you have to have
mastered 10,000 words in order to speak
well and I don't believe that you need
that many words you need to know how to
use
obviously you need words because words
are important but if you develop the
capacity of using words well in
according to the circumstances and then
you can expand your knowledge because it
gives you motivation if you see that in
a certain circumstance you can use these
words and phrases and sentences well
then people are impressed and they say
wow you speak the language well you're
motivated and so the first thing that
you're going to want to focus on and
when you take up the study of a new
language is developing your language
core and I think the Y is pretty obvious
and to have a base in the language that
can then propel you forward when it
comes to speaking language more fluently
so the big question here is how do we go
about developing this language core and
I and I know that Luca is writing a lot
about this in your in his book and so I
know that it's a big topic because a big
part of the book and we won't be able to
go into all of the details but could you
give us some practical tips and maybe
describe the process a bit of what it
takes to develop a language core what we
need to do what I do is I use my own
native tongue or a language and oh very
well as a crutch to learn and figure out
how the other language works how the
other language conveys pieces of
information let us say so the very first
thing that I do from of their beginning
is to compare structures to see
similarities and differences this is
quite important now every languages is
different from one another every
language is obviously another thing so
basically make sure that I have a method
I really like but it's also flexible
work
in the case of building the language
core what I do is I try as I said before
to understand how the language works and
obviously you have to focus on the
differences so what I do basically is I
take I start reading bilingual texts
they have both my language or my
well the simple question is in order to
understand how the other language works
it's not so much people tend to think
about translating attempting to say that
translation could get in the way to be
it represents a huge interference but
you have to consider the fact we have
interference anyway when we start from a
from we always have a system engrained
in our brain which is the the system of
our native tongue that influences the
way we speak and the way we we think and
we can use that as an advantage and we
have to try to avoid interference well
obviously interference to not it's like
it's like noise in in sounds there's
always a background noise they cannot
get eliminate but you can minimize it so
you consider interference as a
background noise I mean they try to act
try to understand how the language works
by using something that is familiar but
you have to use it but not too much so
you have to find a compromise and this
compromise is a result of trying error
so when you're comparing things and then
you're translating for example I
translated you don't necessarily have to
do that you have to make sure that you
don't use your native funk too much
otherwise it gets so the first tip is
you know using your native language as a
crutch so that you can understand the
differences and maybe some of the
similarities as well translates the
translation sir is one way that you can
go about doing that but it's not
necessarily what needs to be used the
the core principle here is noticing the
differences between the languages using
your own native language and there are
many creative ways that one could go
about doing sir yeah yeah I just want to
add that this you know I wanted to say
this because they do remember that a
person sent me a message and said look I
tried to you know ask the most great I
tried to learn everything by heart and
then it didn't work and I told them well
learning things by heart is not exactly
the best way to remain there there are
there's a dearth of possible methods
I don't believe that this was a great
way of dealing with languages because
once again we can say any number of sin
and there are a limit the number of
sentences that you can say or is there
there are no limits so you have to learn
how to build them not learning stocking
fixed sentences that you can use and
then when you you know in these
sentences contain some words and then
when it comes to using these words in a
different context you're at a loss for
words
you didn't develop that capacity so it
sounds like what you're saying is that
developing the language poor is is going
to give you the base so you have the
flexibility to use the language as you
would like and not be stuck with a
particular structure that you're used to
using that is that great that's
absolutely correct it's a way of working
that abides by the so called
neuroplasticity principle we are brain
as you know is beautifully complex and
it changes all the time so we have to
learn how to use it fantastic and so you
given us one tip for developing the
language corner I'm going to be a bit
greedy and ask for another one so the
first and so the first one is making
sure that you use your native long as a
crutch so could you give us maybe one
more tip for two onto the question of
how we can go about developing this
language cool well I would say that
first as I said before you try to
acquire grammar this is another thing
we'll delving into it is just you know
look at rules but our brain works as a a
neural network you know there are some
algorithms that were developed you know
people researchers and scientists were
inspired by how to break work and they
try to find two babies algorithms and I
think that if you try to study
consistently there's
one of the way to develop a language
core you have to study consistently
every day and it's extremely important
not learning things by heart and also
remember to focus on the sounds sound
and even the language core is not just
grammar or patterns it's also sound
pattern so you have to try to develop
things at the same time when we're
talking about the reading listening
speaking and writing these are four
abilities but we give it four we take
for granted visible everybody can do
that so we think oh if you could do one
you can you can also do the other it's
not true there's one other piece of
advice that I feel like giving is try to
develop these capacities at the same
time some you're going to develop pretty
quickly like listening and understanding
some others like speaking it takes more
time but try to develop you try to use
try to studying them and learn a little
at the same time all these try to
develop these huge gap between your
capacity speaking and your capacity of
understanding and that can be fantastic
okay so just to sum up everything that
we spoken about today a language core is
very important for making sure that you
develop the flexibility that is needed
for achieving fluency
in foreign language reasons why a
language pool is important are pretty
clear if you want to you know take off
with your foreign language study and how
can we go about doing that two tips
share today number one use your native
tongue as a crutch to help you notice
the differences and the similarities
between your native tongue and the
language that you were trying to learn
and then make sure that you are
consistent with your study and that you
make sure that you spread your study
evenly among the different skills that
are involved in communication namely
writing speaking listening
writing speaking listening I'm reading
yeah that's it
so you know this is a big topic and
there are lots that we could talk about
so if you could leave a comment below
letting us know what questions you may
have and perhaps hopefully we can you
know answer some of your questions
either some in the comments or we will
make another video so we look forward to
hearing from you my name is David Mansur
a and you are and I'm here with Luca
lamp at yellow in Madrid and we look
forward to seeing you in another video
thank you for watching right